[Music]
air hockey was developed in the late 60s
and early 70s by a group of American
billiard engineers when in play the puck
floats on a thin cushion of air
propelled by players at each end with no
friction the puck moves fast making air
hockey a high-speed game in a game of
air hockey the puck levitates ever so
slightly made possible by a constant
flow of air flowing through perforations
in the play field the play field is made
from a laminated composite material
that's been printed with air hockey
graphics a computerized drill cuts into
three play fields at once in the same
consistent pattern the size of the holes
are a little larger than pin holes
creating over 4,600 perforations in each
air hockey play field an automated tool
carves grooves in a sheet of medium
density fiberboard the board will serve
as a base for the play field air will
circulate in the grooves and exit
through the play field holes next
sawdust is blasted out of the grooves
the grooves fiber board moves through a
glue applicator the rubber roller coats
the top of the board with a small amount
of glue so it doesn't seep into the
grooves as the board exits technicians
move the board onto a stack
[Music]
once the board is in the correct
position the laminate is applied and
aligned with the grooves in the fiber
board a cardboard cover is placed on the
laminate for protection as the stack
moves through a press the weight of the
press squeezes the stack together
ensuring adhesion as the glue cures
meanwhile a craftswoman applies stick on
graphics onto the side apron boards she
opens a pre-cut slot for a coin door and
exposes a hole for a bolt she cuts open
a slot for maintenance access and
removes the panel that will serve as a
door she numbers the door in the side
apron piece so she can match them up
later during installation after applying
artwork to the end panels another
technician assembles curved corner parts
and links metal brackets to the side
apron parts he installs a bracket for a
puck deflector in the center of the end
panel and screws down the corner
connectors
he sets the end panels at an upside-down
position on the work surface and
attaches the sideboards to the corner
connectors this completes the table
apron a lock door is installed in the
plywood floor this will serve as an
interior storage compartment next a
craftsman installs the coin door and
secures it into place he mounts wire
speakers that project sound effects to a
computerized optical system that tracks
the pucks movements once the structure
is spitted with wooden panels the game's
flashing lights and sensor activators
are installed at another station a team
flips a play field over to work on the
back one technician attaches a board
above the open grooves creating a
chamber for airflow the motor and fan
are installed over the small opening
this system will blow air into the
grooves and the playfield perforations
the playfield is turned over and lowered
onto the table structure next aluminum
bumpers are attached to the tables
border as a barrier for the puck during
play a technician installs goal puck
deflectors on the ends and screws in
metal plates over the deflector cups
he installs a lock on each goal
compartment so no one can steal the puck
finally the air hockey table assembly is
complete let the games begin
[Music]